à côté j'ai beaucoup mieux projets dans
un espace son président à un quelqu'un
qui fait autant d'audience aujourd'hui
que roger lanzac en faisait à l'époque
guidon hélène hélène avec les garçons
n'ont et lan sans les garçons ah oui bon
vous êtes d'accord mais ça risque de
faire ton monte avec les garçons alors
c'est bien voici m
[Musique]
donc tu es l'héroïne de hélène et les
garçons sur tf1 après avoir été actrice
dans premiers baisers
est ce que tu peux nous raconter comment
c'est arrivé ce rêve comment tu vas
rencontrer ton producteur jean luc
azoulay
je les ai rencontrés au mans n'avance
occupé des spectacles sur le mans voilà
on l'a rencontré comme ça elle a fait
dorothée voilà l organiser des
spectacles dorothée au mans et c'est
comme ça que tu l'a rencontré parce
qu'il est aussi le producteur il faut le
dire de dorothée oui oui je t'entends
comment avec de rotem très bien ça va
pas de jalousie entre vous vous êtes
dans la même maison de production les
pros le dernier concept ça va c'est
quand il n'y a pas d'histoire quoi
est-ce que hélas est ce que comme
dorothée toi tu n'as pas dû non plus
quand je n'aurai rien mon garçon
s'appelle rachel par contre mais pour le
moment c'est pareil tout les ne faisait
pas le temps d'avoir des jules en fait
oh c'est pas que j'ai pas le temps c'est
bon et toujours pas mais j'ai pas envie
ouais c'est pas à cause du planning non
ça se passe comment une journée d'hélène
ça commence à 8h matin jusqu'à
normalement 20 heures mais ça dépasse
toujours un peu et quand tu rentres chez
toi tu as des textes à apprendre pour le
tu tournes combien d'heures par jour 10
12h à peu près le lundi mardi jeudi
vendredi un bond et le week-end qu'est
ce que tu fais tu restes à paris où j'ai
pas encore tueur retourne voir tes
parents tout le week-end tous les
week-ends oui j'aimerais l'accompagner
moi tu te souviens de belle et sébastien
oui je me souviens bien c'est de belle
et sébastien parce que quand j'étais
petit au cp1 la maîtresse venait me
chercher pour calmer la place et on
chantait avec ma soeur
j'ai souviens quand tu chantais des
chansons de stone et charden oui je me
souviens je faisais stone et ma soeur
comme elle est brune a faisait charte
tu sais que le président adore ça mais
pas à nous en faire un petit bout tous
les deux dit au comble du bonheur de
faire je sais c'est pour vous par
exemple mehdi normandie par exemple par
exemple allez au hasard
les taches rouges blanches et noires sur
lesquels tombent eux l'appui et les
cerisiers blanc mehdi normandie
moment télévision toute une jeunesse
grand moment de télévision
hélène est ce que tu as peur de l'amour
non ça sans rien est-ce que tu as peur
de grossir la plus peur de grossir que
de la mort dis moi hélène tu fais un
feuilleton qui fait 40% de parts de
marché sur tf1 tue pas on en fasse un
petit bout là pour faire un peu remonter
l'audience de lundi matin allongé les
potiches - stéphanie tu y vas tu dit
cole vous en pensez quoi
professeur hausse et pas de refus
thierry parce que un vous avez parlé de
la mort a refait toujours de ces
l'audience et puis 2 ce qui est encore
plus grave le président a chanté et le
retrait du président chante we may
président votre chanson n'a pas été très
après il ya les dépêchons nous de vous
êtes en place
très bien alors emmanuel si tu veux bien
commencé salut tu viens pour le casting
toi aussi
bah oui vous nous aussi on a nous
l'annonçons interview tu sais le canard
de dechavanne mais non c'est pas de
cheval ces petits riens ardisson maurice
et la ccoo faut toujours ces deux là ah
bon pourtant thierry ardisson quand même
sabot tu trouves
moi j'aime bien le char wingles la belle
cravate
ah oui c'est vrai mais c'est quand même
important il ya deux choses que je
regarde c'est un garçon ses yeux et ce à
travers leurs homards pour copains où
regarder
je crois que c'est lui qui sort de
chavannes mais non thierry ardisson
attendait
ça lui fait tout et thierry ardisson oui
c'est moi vous venez pour la danse
oui c'est ça c'est pourquoi c'est pour
le juste prix
non c'est pour une nouvelle sitcom que
nous préparons sur france 2 thierry et
les filles aux d'un joli titre à sa
merci c'est moi qui les trouvaient alors
qu'est ce que vous avez fait jusqu'à
maintenant
moi j'étais petit johnny supermarchés et
moi dans les discothèques et toi moi
j'ai fait beaucoup de poterie poterie
potiche c'est pas loin alors dites moi
quel est votre rêve moi c'est d'être une
vedette vide et et n'importe quoi mais
une faute ah oui et toi et moi c'est
d'être une star une grande stars comme
madonna christine ockrent
oui c'est vrai que c'est pas mal de
choses et toi c'est quoi ton rêve moi ce
serait de faire le printemps de bourges
à bas les filles je suis désolé c'est
elle qui est engagée parce que sur cette
chaîne
quand on parle de bourges on a gagné d
avance
[Applaudissements]
content très content réussir sa fille
mais je suis sûr et leurs biens alors
comme il est maintenant tradition comme
le dirait professeur rollin je vais
faire un petit cadeau à hélène comme à
tous les invités importants du monde de
la télé qui viennent alors elle est j'ai
deux petits cadeaux à vous faire d'abord
ce petit cristal de roche car je sais
que votre père a dans les vielles
pierres et que vous êtes comme votre
père vous aimait les vielles pierres
mais cette pire là il est un peu
symbolique car je voudrais que et mes
adhérents voudrait que comme cette
pierre votre carré votre carrière brille
et dure très longtemps
voilà c'est petit
je vous ai préparé maintenant c'est un
petit buzz je ne sais pas si vous
souhaite à toutes les paroles un petit
pot pourri des laines car vous savez
qu'il ya trois chansons sur hélène alors
seul sur le sable les pieds dans l'eau
mon rêve était trop beau l'été qui
s'achève tu partiras dans ton pays loin
là-bas et l'es6 je t'écris aux kerguelen
c'est parce qu'ici sans le savoir si à
laisser quelqu'un qui terre et l'air et
l'aide technique suis pas vers les
cartons mais je t'écris quand même que
je t'aime et les olalala voilà c'était
bravo bravo président et si vite fait
bien fait comme on dit à montluçon gens
très bien et bien hélène merci c'était
vraiment royal top on peut dire que tu
envoies le bois à bientôt tort
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]